hello everyone and welcome to the most
requested game from the air things
masters 2022. it's magnus carlsen versus
pragananda and as the title suggests yes
that is exactly what happened now it's
only a matter of how it happened so uh
without further ado let's check it out
magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 as it's already on the board uh
we have knight to f6 by prague c for e6
knights to f3 and d5 we go into the
queen's gambit declined knight to c3 and
now going for a very sharp uh semitash
with c5 asking do you want to go for
some very early complications with c
captures and d5 maybe bishop to g5 maybe
uh well basically i think the sharpest
continuations arise after c captures on
d5 but magnus just goes for the
very solid e3
uh we have knight to c6 and now c
captures on d5 with e captures and
bishop to b5 so nicely continuing
development nothing new or out of the
ordinary happening here uh now before uh
developing with bishop to d6 prague
first decides to go for another capture
in the center we have e cap c captures e
captures and bishop to d6 now he's ready
to castle so both players castle magnus
castles prague castles with h3h6 some
useful moves being thrown around and
rook to e1 magnus grabs hold of the open
e file and prague continues development
we have bishop to f5 very nice
developing square for the bishop you can
see it's a very powerful piece on this
diagonal also the dark square bishop
doing good job on this diagonal and now
magnus throws in a knight on e5 and as
usual in similar positions you never
really want to capture on e5 unless you
absolutely have to because then white
gets the capture with this pawn and then
the pawn on e5 controls a lot of very
important squares here so if you don't
have to do this you don't do this so
rook to c8 prague just continues
developing and now bishop to f4 magnus
does the same we have rook to e8 and now
rook to c1 so both players are nicely
developed
magnus has yet to develop his queen and
also prague needs to do the same to
connect the rooks and now uh
interestingly there is a game uh that
reached this exact same position by
another indian grand master uh and it
was uh from last year's in 2021 from the
tata steel uh india uh edition uh
between lakuang liam and vidit and david
played rook to e6 here and he won a very
nice game with this but here prague goes
for queen to b6 and it is now as of move
14 that we have a completely new game
and interestingly uh queen to b6 is the
engine's first choice so uh prague
obviously knows of the game um uh la
quang liam versus vidit and he made an
improvement on that game and now as this
is now a completely new territory it's
magnus to move and he decides to go for
bishop captures in c6 uh thing is okay
that the bishop might be attacked at
some point then the b2 pawn might become
weak so you might continue just
developing with queen to d2 and put um
some defense to the b2 pawn so you don't
really care about the the bishop here
but magnus decides to trade we have
bishop captures b captures and now
knight to a4 attacks the queen and
defends the b-2 pawn this way so queen
to a6 getting the queen out of harm's
way now putting pressure on the knight
making it a little bit harder for the
queen to be developed and now rook to e3
and rook to e3 is a very nice idea by
magnus he wants to either go rook to g3
maybe in some lines putting pressure on
the king side sort of going for for an
attack
or doubling up on the c file so rook c1
rook to c3 the knight here attacking c6
uh it's it's a weak pawn it's a
backwards a weak pawn so this is what
magnus wants to play against so knight
to e4 and grabbing more space here also
taking away the g3 square from the rook
and now we have f3 kicking away the
knight from e4 knight to g5 and now rook
eat the c3 uh ready to capture the pawn
on c6 and there isn't all that much
prague can do about this uh if he
doesn't want to play uh something very
passive so instead we have queen to b7
now saying okay you are welcome to to
capture the pawn here but um well the
bishop on f4 would be hanging so magnus
needs to do something about this
otherwise this knight can't really move
uh and you could play bishop captures on
g5 this is with um
with tempo so for example bishop
captures h captures and now g4 and yes
in this line you get to capture the pawn
for example but look at your king's side
i mean there are too many pieces on the
board to be playing like this with both
the rooks the bishop pair and the queen
still on the board uh it would be
it would not be possible to survive this
with white so instead after queen to b7
magnus brings the bishop back with
bishop to h2 and now knight to e6
getting ready to bring the knight over
to f4 progresses uh you are welcome to
grab the c6 spawn i'm now going for the
attack and it's uh well it's definitely
a deadly there magnus has to decide
whether to
prepare some defenses or to go after the
pawn because if you can capture the pawn
and not
lose uh to the attack then it's probably
a winning position if not then it's
probably a losing position so magnus
goes for it he plays knight captures on
c6 and now uh prague will plays knight
to f4 and this is a very interesting
move because uh before this knight to
form both players uh seem to have missed
a
completely winning idea by prague so
knight the f4 is winning but not right
away first we trade off the bishops and
only then knights to f4 and now it's
much stronger as how do you uh prevent
rook to e2 going after the the g2 pawn
even if you defend the g2 pawn somehow
knights the e2 and both rooks are
getting attacked so there are too many
threats here and the magnets will not be
able to defend uh
all of them so this was uh a little bit
stronger uh so uh probably went knights
to f4 instead and now uh magnus gets a
chance to fight back now he just brings
knight to the e5 and he says all right
now the attack is over uh so here bishop
captures an e5 d captures an e5 by
magnus and now knight the d3 an
excellent score for the knight but
magnus just plays rook captures on c8
and trades off uh both pairs of rooks so
uh rook captures on c8 rook captures on
c8 queen captures and c8 and now bishop
to g3 creating a breeding square for the
king on h2 so what can prague play here
well he does have a past the d-pawn so
he pushes it pawn to d4 now this is what
we're what we're playing for now we have
b3 by magnus and now queen to c6 getting
the queen to a little bit of a more more
of an active square so queen to d2 and
now we have king to h7 both players just
improving their position we have king to
h2 and now bishop back to g6 we have
queen to a5 now
magnus goes after the a7 pawn and we
have queen to c1 prague offers the a7
pawn for some very very interesting
counter play and magnus goes for it he
plays queen captures on a7 so another
deadly there uh accepted uh
attacking the pawn here now prague plays
queen to e3 defending the pawn and well
it seems like uh he has a queen and the
knight
against the the king and the bishop here
and the queen a queen and knight are
such a deadly combo in chess that uh
very often they they can you know create
combinations that are well impossible to
not only uh defend against but also just
to predict so here magnus has to play
something and he has to play uh some
knight to b6 or queen to a5 but
definitely not the move he played here
magnus played knight to c3 uh sort of
offering the knight but of course the
knight cannot be captured as the the
queen on e3 would be captured but still
it's a move that loses the game so here
magnus gives prague another opportunity
to
to claim a full point so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
only winning move of prague
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
incredible series of moves uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show uh it is knight to f4 uh that's the
good stuff uh because now we're still
threatening to win the night so how do
you defend the problem is you cannot
capture the knight because queen
captures with check and once we defend
queen d2 check again we'll pick up the
knight so obviously that's out of the
question another thing you could do is
just bring the knight back to where it
came from but now knight e2 and now how
do you defend against checkmate the
knight covers both the g3 and g1 there's
just no uh defense against mate uh
whatever your player you're getting
checkmated bishop moves anywhere still
this checkmate the knight covers the g3
square so instead after knight to f4 we
have knight to d1 magnus finds a very
nice way of of saving the knight but uh
only temporarily because now uh queen to
d2 very important not to play queen to
e2 we still have to keep an eye on the
knight so if the bishop uh captures
knight then queen captures with check
and now we don't care if g3 then check
we pick up the knight and if the king
moves we also don't care just queen to
d2 and look at the knight how it's
nicely trapped here again it's
impossible to save the knight so after
queen to d2 knight to f2 by magnus again
nicely defending but now prague will
plays knight to e2 and now how do you
defend against queen e1 queen to g1
checkmate again
uh
something will will simply have to be uh
given by magnus in order to survive the
attack a little bit longer so he plays
h4 tries to create some breeding room
for his king but now queen to e1 and
again very very nasty stuff here queen
to d7 trying to help out with the white
queen in any way possible but now comes
the very clean knight captures on g3 and
uh if you capture with the king then you
lose the queen that's the problem with
queen 37 but no other movie is better
the problem is if you play king captures
queen captures an e5 with check you
cannot go to h2 you have to play king to
a light square and then bishop here and
just
loses the white queen and of course if
f4 this is also just bad queen to e3
check will be played and now whatever we
play uh well
the knight will fall so nothing works
here for uh for uh for magnus so after
knight captures on g3 queen captures on
d4 so we had to give up the piece uh now
comes knight to f1 with check king to h3
and now knight to e3 again with uh so
many deadly threats the knight is now
hanging so queen to b2 magnus defends it
uh and here there are many winning moves
a queen to g1 is a very nice one going
for a sort of a forced checkmating
sequence but prague finds the simplest
of solutions and he plays bishop to c2
so it was in this position on move 39
that magnus carlsen resigned the game
and what uh what a spectacular victory
for for young prague crushing the world
champion like this and yes uh he is the
youngest player ever to defeat magnus uh
wells ever since magnus became world
champion as prague was only 16 years old
so here you resign uh well the knight is
hanging and
there's no good move here for white if
you try something like knight to g4 then
you no longer control the h1 square
we're gonna play queen h1 check king g3
queen captures king here and now as our
good friend the bishop is covering all
the light squares that means uh well one
check uh will be checkmate and that
means knight to the d5 check is check my
knight covers e3 bishop covers e4 and f5
queen covers g3 and that's it all of the
other squares are taken by uh by white's
pieces and that's pretty much it g5 is
covered by the pawn so of course this
would be checkmate so magnus did not
wait for this after bishop to c2 he
resigned and yes what a brilliant
victory by young prague against the
world champion
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it and thank you very much
for for suggesting such a such a nice
one i would like to thank anwar the 95
american flag numa david kimura doug
reynolds uh uh even sterling and pp
poopoo for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the air
things masters
until it finishes uh thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day